LARRY DAVID:
Four score and seven years ago,
our fathers brought forth
to this continent a new nation.
Ladies and gentleman...
-Abraham Lincoln!
-Abraham-- Right.
Let's give him a big round
of applause.
Like you know anything
about fashion.
It is such an honor,
Mr. President.
You don't know shit.
I know you look ridiculous.
-Yeah, fine.
-How about that?
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Hey, hey!
Flowers, balloons, Larry David.
What could be better?
Can I give you a little tip?
If you're gonna confront
somebody,
it's better to do it
with pants on.
It's hard to take a person
seriously wearing shorts.
(CHEERING)
Everybody in the big johnson
community knows
you can't wear underwear.
There's a big johnson community?
I'd like to see if I could join.
How are you getting in
the big johnson community
-without a big johnson?
-You can't.
-LARRY: Hey.
-Yeah.
-I need you to do me a favor.
-Uh, I can't do it.
-No, no, you gotta do it.
-I already got my sweats on.
What is it, an immutable law
of physics?!
Once you're in sweats
you can't get out?
Newton's Law of sweats?!
I think you can introduce me
as a Renaissance man.
-Oh!
-A guy who speaks six languages.
You want to impress people
with lies?
How else do you impress them?
I'm gonna fuck you up.
-Get the hell out of here.
-With pleasure.
-RICHARD LEWIS: Thanks a lot.
-Fuck you,
-and I'll see you tomorrow.
-Fucking idiot.
Please, just go.
(GARGLING)
-Okay, Larry, you gotta go.
-Larry, get out!
-Get out!
-Get the fuck out, Larry.
-What the fuck are you doing?!
-Oh, God.
Get the fuck out.
I want you out!
-You're kicking me out?
-And you can go too.
-Yes, Jon Hamm.
-Hey, you're gettin' kicked out!
-Out!
-All right.
-Okay. Eh...
-We should, uh...
-Eh.
♪ ("CURB YOUR ENTHUSIASM"
THEME PLAYS) ♪
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪